اذا اليوم تستمر المعارك في اكثر من نقطه
تتركز بشكل كبير جنوب قطاع غزه وفي
المنطقه الوسطى سنبدا من الجنوب حيث كنا
نشاهد قبل قليل الفيديو الذي نشرته كتائب
القسام القسام قالت في الفيديو او كانت
تقول دوما انها تشتبك بالاسلحه الرشاشه
الخفيفه مع قوات الاحتلال في منطقه
خانيونس ونحن راينا ذلك بالفعل في الفيديو
المنشور لكتائب الق قسام الاشتباكات من
مسافات قصيره جدا بين الطرفين ايضا القسام
تقول انها
تستهدف دبابات اسرائيليه اليوم تم استهداف
دبابه ميركافا واحده على الاقل ولكن نلاحظ
مساله
اساسيه نعتقد على سبيل المثال ان الدبابات
دوما تستهدف بالاسلحه المحموله على الكتف
لفتني لقطه مرت في الفيديو المصور هو ان
هناك دبابه كانت تسير ولكن تسير ب بطئ
شديد في شارع ضيق في مكان ما من قطاع غزه
تقدم احد ال تقدم احد المقاومين من جانب
الدبابه وقام بوضع عبوه عليها عبوه صغيره
ربما هي شواط قد تكون او او عبوه اخرى ثم
تراجع عن هذه الدبابه وراينا انفجار بصرف
النظر عن حجم الانفجار الذي لاحظناه في
هذه الصور ولكن هذا يعني ان حتى ال اليات
يتم مهاجمه هذه الاليات من جميع المناطق
حيث تستطيع كتائب القسام وبقيه فصائل
المقاومه في خانيونس ما زال القتال مستمرا
عند الاطراف لا سما في شرق خان يونس وايضا
هناك بعض المعارك المحدوده في منطقه معا
عند الجنوب ولكن هناك قصف اسرائيلي شديد
حيث لا تتمكن الوحدات من اختراق مدينه
خانيونس وايضا هناك بعض الاشتباكات قليلا
الى الشرق ولكن دون الوصول الى عبسان وبن
سهيلا التين تتعرضان لقصف شديد اليوم
بالانتقال الى المنطقه الوسطى ايضا كما
ذكر الياس كرام من الميدان هذا القوس
نصيرات البريج المغازي ما زالت
الاشتباكات تدور فيه عند اكثر من محور لا
سما المناطق الشرقيه من المغازي والبريج
والسراط ولكن هناك كما يبدو بعض عمليات
اعاده الانتشار في الزوايده ايضا تقدمت
قليلا القوات قوات الاحتلال وما زالت
تحاول الدخول ومهاجمه دير البلح بشكل كامل
هناك مقاومه شديده وهناك استهدافات مباشره
تستعين بالطائرات عندما لا تتمكن من
التقدم بشكل كبير ولكن ما حدث اليوم ان
منطقه دير البلح شهدت اعاده انتشار او
اعاده تموضع للقوات الاسرائيليه
نحو الشرق بعض الشيء وايضا باتجاه المناطق
الشماليه تراجعت الاليات واعادت التموضع
كل ذلك والمنطقه الحدوديه تشهد استمرارا
للقصف من الطائرات الاسرائيليه الملاحظ
اليوم ايضا ان المنطقه الشماليه شهدت قصفا
عنيفا ولا نستطيع ان نقول انه توقف ولكن
هذا القصف تركز عند المناطق على طول الش
شمال والمناطق الشرقيه